when your relationship goes from
sizzling to fizzling it means they're
too chicken to say your relationship is
DOA
there's reportedly another new dating
Trend out there called fizzling
and no bill I don't mean the sex act
using Diet Coke and a pack of mental
Mentos
still can't get my upholstery clean
wild man
according to the dating app hinge
fizzling is when daters don't want to
tell someone they're no longer
interested they become slower and
shorter in their responses before
stopping altogether it's a technique
that was first pioneered by men
but so-called relationship experts say
fizzlers typically don't want to have
direct conversations about their
feelings and most people Fizz because
they're scared and don't want to hurt
the other person
instead of getting straight to the point
like when I told Kudlow no more hot tub
till you treat that fungus your toenails
look like candy corn
yeah yeah Kudlow
fizzlers also typically have their minds
already made up about ending things but
instead of doing it directly they put
the other person on the back burner
until someone better comes along back
burner what is that a kitchen term who
wrote this abroad oh sexist would say
me I find the best way to end a
relationship is just to get it over with
treat it like a Band-Aid when you're
done just rip it off then put it in a
box with all your other old Band-Aids
I almost have enough for a quilt
so uh cat
um we know the worst way that you've
been dumped
um do you fizzle
all right did you physically I'm now
married
you can still do when you're married
just do it before you have kids okay uh
no this is like this has been around
forever everybody does like everybody's
done this everybody's done this
everyone's had this done to them it's
gotten a lot more difficult with social
media though yeah because you can see
what people are doing you can be like oh
well I just saw you were online 32
minutes ago and I texted you 31 minutes
ago so what's the problem
um
so fizzling me never really worked
because I will get aggressive yeah I can
tell yeah but it's a lot of people they
want to have the direct confrontation
with somebody but that's yeah that's the
that's a little selfish when you demand
you know to have somebody break up with
you in person then you're just making
excuses like oh they're probably just
busy with work they're not no they're
not no one's ever too busy with work for
sex yes unless you're a sex worker
you
can clap for that one that was that was
pretty good yeah
how ironic I got clapping from uh Bill
what's the worst way you broke up with
someone that's a great question you are
a lifelong bachelor how much time do you
have I think I break Hearts like I break
wind
I think I've been fizzled before I've
probably fizzled a few myself yeah
um look just because gen Z calls it by a
different name doesn't mean it's
different immediately I'm letting you
down easy right I'm just been around for
a long time right cat yeah
wow that was great so you guys when
[Laughter]
[Applause]
here's what I'm gonna say you know just
because you know you use it a different
way just doesn't make a difference yeah
just spoke in a different way it's you
put that in your Tick Tock yeah exactly
that was strange Tyrus I always assume
there are two ways that men break up
with women you get caught doing
something really really awful or you
force them to slow you slowly hate you
over time right so you you like you're
like that you're like the the bucket of
water boiling the Frog oh
uh Greg why do you do this to me
not you're not a there's no such thing
as a fizzler
it's called just being a man stuck in a
relationship with a really mean
overbearing woman who has evidence on
you that's all it is
shares your bank accounts she is the
custody of the kids
she knows that you did when you were
younger oh my God so you just sit there
and you
dream about what life would be like if a
truck just came through your house and
hit you
but then with your luck you'd live
you need to be stuck in a wheelchair
stealing in the corner hoping some way
somehow you can lean towards the
sunlight but you can't because
she's there
saying what are you thinking about
I'm gonna cry but no I thought that was
good oh yeah well done
you Emily I bet you have some sorted
stories to tell no are you a
heartbreaker or they break your heart or
do you even have a heart to bring
like this was so confusing to me I don't
understand not being able to have a
critical conversation directly and
immediately like the thought God oh I'm
sorry that I actually have this is my
nightmare
I know this is oh my God you must be
normal yeah yeah that's right I'll say
this everything about this to me just
screams insecurity lack of a spine like
I don't I don't know any I mean no
offense like I don't know any man that
would do that I mean you know there's
two women on the couch right there
because I just I don't think any I don't
think any oh I don't
[Applause]
photography I
I just genuinely don't understand this I
think the person fizzling I have zero
respect for and then the person who
would take it like why don't you just
then say hi like I don't know I don't
know pretty clearly young maybe I'm too
old yeah and the Social Media stuff and
the minutes online like I don't I don't
get that all right well we learned
nothing
and you are awesome yes yes have you
ever lost an argument
no
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else